nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour olivier
très heureux de vous retrouver ce matin
alors on le disait l'interview
d'emmanuel macron à la chaîne américaine
cbs
à l'écran une polémique notamment sur la
destruction des constructions de
l'histoire est-ce que c'est choquant
pour vous c'est surtout olivier un
nouvel aveu un du logiciel
intellectuelle des manuels macro et plus
largement il faut le dire de notre
classe politique
au 19e siècle auguste comte il disait
que les morts gouverne les vivants
emmanuel macron lui en 2021 il déclare
effectivement vous l'avez des oliviers
dans cet entretien à cbs qu'il faut
déconstruire notre propre histoire avec
cet anglais donne deux aéroports depuis
l'elysée alors on me rétorquera bien
entendu je l'entends déjà que cette
déclaration était notamment question de
la discrimination et du racisme mais
cette phrase en réalité elle est criant
d'une idéologie qui dépasse largement ce
cadre car voici venu le temps du globish
tout puissant qui incarne cette
obsession de déconstruction qui ne se
cache plus le candidat mâcon
rappelez-vous avait déjà avoué son
désintérêt pour la nation à lyon début
2010 est je cite il n'y a pas de culture
française il ya une culture en france et
les diverses
alors ces déclarations à quatre ans
d'intervalle venant du chef de l'état
sont tout sauf anecdotique
elles sont l'affirmation de reniement
profond de ce qui fait la france
séculaire aujourd'hui ce sont donc les
vivants qui congédie les morts et
emmanuel marc macron tente de poursuivre
son opération pas ses propres et nous
allons essayer de comprendre pourquoi ce
matin olivier alors nicolas
à quoi est-ce que vous attribuez ses
déclarations et selon vous qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière alors en réalité c'est
assez simple malheureusement j'écoutais
sur une chaîne concurrente cette semaine
aux députés de la majorité qui affermit
affirmé que si emmanuel macron s'était
présenté à l'élection présidentielle
c'est qu'il aimait la france et ben on
peut autres illicitement douter de son
amour pour cette france éternelle et
séculaire la question que l'on doit se
poser aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi nos
élites ont sombré intellectuellement et
culturellement c'est vers la zone et
pour nous imposer ce prêchi prêcha et
nous vanter cette société liquide
premier élément de réponse c'est
l'idéologie emmanuel macron et le vrp le
plus dévoué pour nous imposer cette
feuille de route car il est bien
plus emballé manuel macron par une
france déracinés et vidé de sa substance
qu'il rêve de se transformer en start up
vous le savez depuis son élection dans
ce domaine
à un an de la fin de son mandat c'est un
cuisant échec un exemple criant nous
confrères des échos révélé la semaine
dernière que la france n'apparaissait
pas dans le classement des 50
entreprises mondiales les plus
innovantes
pourtant ce n'est pas faute de nous
avoir servi matin midi et soir
l'innovation mais peut-être qu'ils
subissent et celle suffisait pas
revanchard l'olivier de traverser la rue
pour briller sur la scène mondiale en
termes d'innovation ou pas en réalité il
ya des pays qui réussissent dans
l'innovation et des pays qui ne sont
rien dans ce domaine et le discours d'
emmanuel macron la station elf en 2017
est resté à quai et on ne parlera même
pas ici de la situation effroyable de la
france de crise sanitaire totalement
exemple est incapable de se défendre
tout seul en termes d'innovations
médicales la becquée est venu de
l'étranger vous le savez rien n'a été
produit sur notre sol donc finalement
l'idéologie de la start up se cassent
lamentablement la figure et il ne reste
qu'à emmanuel macron la ridicule
souveraineté européenne et la
désastreuse ou aux cultures deuxième
élément de réponse et un mépris partagé
pour l'enracinement combiner un
appauvrissement intellectuel notre
classe politique pour une bonne partie
finalement d'élites françaises
la mondialisation doit être imposé aux
français pour supplanter tout ce qui
ressemble à la nation et venir à bout de
l'enracinement souveraineté frontières
légitimité politique protection des
intérêts des français
notre histoire et surtout notre notre
langue car lorsque vous rabaisser un
pays à sa capacité d'innovation de
flexibilisation et dubé risation c'est
ignorer ostensiblement que notre
histoire et notre seule boussole pour
l'avenir c'est une totale en hérésie de
vouloir faire de la france un rayon de
supermarché avec des caisses
automatiques et cette obsession du tout
marché révèle en fait n'appauvrisse mans
intellectuelle d'une partie de notre
classe politique qui ne réfléchit
absolument plus deux exemples mais je
pourrait inciter mille autres hier
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement s'est excusé de ne pas
avoir remercié les assistantes
maternelles 1,1 point qu'on l'avait
alerté sur instagram
puis vous avez marlène schiappa
secrétaire d'état qui milite pour des
quartiers ça relou on passera sur la
marelle
de jean michel blanquer arrière dans un
centre de loisirs à quand le jeu de
billes il ya quel moment à quel moment
ce pays s'était fourvoyé à ce point pour
produire des élites à ce point immature
vous imaginez tristan mendès-france
pardon ou de gaulle s'arrêter la nation
sur titeuf
on parle à un sabir préadolescents
olivier alors nicolas qu'est ce qui
éloigne selon vous ces élites dont vous
parlez et la france en réalité nos
élites un refus de se poser des
questions sur la france eh bien c'est la
preuve irréfutable olivier d'un
effondrement intellectuelle et
culturelle qui engage tous les français
dans une voie dangereuse sans leur
demander leur avis par obsession et par
idéologie
l'idéologie en réalité elle a remplacé
la réflexion et à ramollit le cerveau
ainsi que l'épaisseur politique et les
convictions sont devenus elle-même des
antilles un petit kit et politique la
bêtise de la déconstruction nous vole
notre identité broie nos héritages
saccage notre patrimoine et ne veut plus
entendre parler de la france parce qu
affirmer l'existence d'une culture et
une identité française c'est concevoir
notre nation comme un bien commun en
réalité les morts gouverne vivent avec
cette phrase auguste comte avait
merveilleusement décrit notre obligation
à l'héritage ou passer de ce pays
nos élites incarnées par emmanuel macron
tente de déconstruire ce que nous avons
de plus cher c'est à dire notre histoire
mais elle n'est pas faite pour être
déconstruites cette grande histoire et
notre légitimité pour affronter l'avenir
et continuer à exister
il est faut encore que nos élites
réapprennent l'histoire de france
vivement olivier que les réels des
écoles a dream merci nicolas on vous
retrouve jeudi prochain pour l'édito
politique de la matinale en attendant on
peut vous revoir un sur les réseaux
sociaux